the price of ingredients seems to be
going through the roof at the moment so
whether you've got a big family like me
or you're just cooking for yourself it
pays to keep an eye on costs but that
doesn't mean you have to compromise on
taste my ultimate thrifty recipes prove
that whatever your budget you can still
cook sensational food
first a breakfast to cheer you up
whatever your budget my mom's thrifty
cinnamon eggy bread with quick stewed
apples for lunch on a shoestring superb
smoky bacon sweet corn and potato soup
it's amazing how cheap the ingredients
are that go into this
and helping me cook dinner a woman who
fed her kids like kings even when money
was tight my fantastic mum i love what
you used to do with the leftover
rockstar soup it's amazing i used to
make it stretch for like five or six
dinners oh you don't exactly it's not
that bad mom and i are cooking a classic
thrifty main course of braised oxtail
but with a chinese twist
and we're sticking in the east with an
oriental put chili poached pears with
star anise dust
lovely these are my ultimate thrifty
recipes breakfast lunch and dinner
starting with a breakfast that's cheap
as chips but never fails to delight
irresistible cinnamon eggy bread with
quick stewed apples
i've never forgotten i think i was about
six years of age when mum brought this
huge tray of eggy bread to the table and
it was like wow
mum we've died and gone to heaven start
off with a slightly stale bread
four or five day old loaf left over if
it's a fresh bread then it absorbs too
much of the egg so therefore it gets
soggy you never get it fried and crisp
and if you're not gonna use it for
breadcrumbs eggy bread is a must
in france they call it pan perdu the
lost loaf
now eggy bread is great on its own but
serving it with stewed apples is
delicious so the secret here
keeping the skins on it's a lot of
flavor in the skin and also it stops the
apple from breaking down too quickly
they get these nice chunks as opposed to
a sort of apple puree
[Music]
now get your pan nice and hot and
sprinkle a couple of tablespoons of
sugar take the sugar down to a light
caramel
it's quite incredible how cheap it is to
make this and yet it was so filling
if you haven't got apples this recipe
will work pretty much with any fruit
you've got in
don't be scared to mix a pear and an
apple a banana and a pineapple just chew
it
lightly toss in the caramel
get a little knob of butter
that makes a nice toffee apple flavor
really simple
now
you can see what's happening the apples
are caramelizing but they're staying
intact because the skins on the apple
and the caramel's turned into this nice
rich butterscotch sauce
once you've glazed all the apples a
couple of tablespoons of water in there
bring that bowl and let that cook out
now the eggs
three whole eggs
whisk up the eggs
add about four tablespoons of milk
you want the egg
thick and rich
and then lightly sprinkle in a couple of
tablespoons of sugar
that sweetens up
the mixture and when you start frying
the bread
it caramelizes it beautifully
a teaspoon of powdered cinnamon that
gives the bread that really nice spicy
deliciousness
apples are glazing beautifully
and put them on a low heat and get a pan
on now for the bread
a teaspoon of oil that stops the butter
from burning butter in
as that starts frothing get your bread
in gonna be pretty quick now now you
don't leave the bread soaking
drain
and in the pan
once your egg bread has browned flip it
over
90 seconds each side
that butter gives that nice golden brown
color of that egg
[Music]
beautiful
absolutely beautiful
it's quite remarkable isn't it a couple
of eggs splash of milk leftover apples
and all of a sudden you've got this
stunning breakfast
[Music]
now my apples they've all delays
beautifully
get a nice spoon of that amazing juice
and drizzle that over
wow
if my mum saw me doing this she'd kill
me you're getting all posh again no no
i'm using a touch of iced sugar to make
it look stunning
and that for me takes me back to when i
was six years of age
and i thought
i just won the lottery that
is incredible
thank you brett
[Music]
you won't get more breakfast for your
buck my mum's incredibly delicious
cinnamon eggy bread with quick stewed
apples
[Music]
knowledge is crucial if you want to make
sure you're getting the best ingredients
for your money
so to help you shop smarter here's a
closer look at some of the key
ingredients i'll be cooking with today
[Music]
first for lunch i'm using bacon
deliciously seductive in asani and great
for adding flavor and texture to thrifty
dishes because a little goes a long long
way
my favorite bacon is traditional cured
italian pancetta
rich and strong in flavor it brings
extra depth to salads stews and soups
but a great cheaper alternative is
streaky bacon and it's what i'll be
using for my thrifty lunch
styroneese is an aromatic and a seedy
star-shaped pot widely used in chinese
cooking
fantastic simmered in savory broths or
infused in sweet puddings styronese is
widely available in supermarkets but for
the thrifty it can be bought in bulk
from spacious asian grocers
properly stalled in an airtight
container the pods will last for several
months
oxtail is pretty much what it says on
the tin the tail bones of a bull or cow
perhaps it's best known guys is as octal
soup but this cut is also a great value
for money choice for brazing
if you shop around it's hard to find a
cheaper cut of red meat
cooked long and slow they'll yield
anxious chunks of melt-in-your-mouth
beef
i'll be cooking mine chinese style for a
delicious thrifty dinner
my ultimate thrifty lunch would always
be a soup soups are really versatile and
great for using up ingredients you've
already got but best of all i absolutely
love them
and this is one of my favorites a
comforting smoky bacon sweet corn and
potato soup
thrifty for me is about ingredients that
are in the cupboard
smoky bacon
onions potatoes sweet corn
it's amazing how cheap the ingredients
are they go into this
get your bacon and just cut into nice
chunks i want these nice bite-sized
pieces smoky chunky and just
absolutely delicious it's almost like an
american corn chowder
potatoes give it starch thickness
sweet corn gives it that glossy
delicious flavor
a couple of baileys they're always
hanging around if they're not in your
cupboard they're on someone's drive so
ask to borrow them
they are so powerful and it goes
brilliantly well with the onions and the
bacon
bay leaves in
a couple of potatoes
it's incredible how far you can stretch
something out especially when you bulk
it with potatoes slice them
and dice them
nice and chunky
soups are a fantastic way to use up
leftover veg or meat that might
otherwise go to waste and if you make it
in bulk freeze it in individual portions
and save on lunches throughout the week
so you can see already how hearty and
robust the soup is it's a delicious
combination
onions bacon potatoes
and now
some fresh leeks
open up the leak into four
give that
a nice wash
licks often have soil left in their tops
so it's important to clean them
thoroughly
start sweating that down
we haven't even got a corn in there yet
and already it's looking
and smelling incredible
add salt but remember you've got bacon
in there which is salty so proceed with
caution really important to sweat those
potatoes off i love getting that flavor
from the smoky bacon
in with the potatoes
now once the leek is sweated off
creamed corn
a popular side dish in the states
creamed corn is made from fresh frozen
or even tinned corn cooked with onion
butter and cream and can be bought ready
made that starts to give the foundation
the soup
off the cream corn add the sweet corn
then
your stock
don't flood the soup
just bring the stock to underneath the
ingredients you can always add very
different to take away
homemade chicken stock is so cheap to
make just boil up your roast chicken
bones with a few fresh veg and freeze in
batches for when you need it
lighten the load with a touch of milk
that gives a really nice bright color
now bring that up to the ball
turn it down and let it simmer for 12 to
15 minutes
as it cooks slowly the starch thickens
the soup the bacon renders
and that leek
onion starts to puree and the corn just
shines
okay next we're gonna make the american
cheese biscuits in the uk they're known
as scones but in america they're called
biscuits
[Music]
first put plain flour into a sieve
add baking powder and sift both into a
bowl
next add some salt
pepper and grated mature cheddar cheese
mix the dry ingredients then make it
well in the center
pour in double cream and gently combine
with a wooden spoon
turn your dough out onto a floured
surface and knead for a few seconds only
if you overwork it your cheese biscuits
won't rise
roll out your dough to about two
centimetres thick and cut into four
centimeter round biscuits
[Applause]
place well apart on a lined baking sheet
and leave to rest on the tray for about
10 minutes
then brush the top of each biscuit with
melted butter
and bake for about 30 minutes at 160
degrees c in a preheated oven
when your cheese biscuits are well risen
and a beautiful golden brown remove
deliciously moorish served hot or cold
time to dole out my thrifty lunch
i always like to leave a soup to stand
or rest
it looks richer it gets rid of all the
stock
i like to have two thirds ingredient one
third of the stock so it looks like a
nice delicious
chunky soup
into the bowl
[Music]
beautiful tin sweet corn a leek potato
and some streaky bacon but it doesn't
look like it's just come out of a store
cupboard that is proper hearty food
[Music]
served with my american style cheese
biscuits this thrifty lunch may have
been made on a shoestring but without an
ounce of compromise on freshness and
flavor
[Music]
there's one person who knows all about
being thrifty in the home kitchen it's
my mum god i love you i love you too
now you're gonna help me cook dinner and
give me some valuable tips on how to
save money in the home kitchen right i
will do you will do excellent see easy
peasy
for my ultimate thrifty dinner we're
gonna make an amazing spicy braised
oxtail
followed by a deliciously juicy pudding
chilli poached pears with star and east
dust
now
oxtail was something that we grew up
with yeah there's something you can do
in the morning and put it in the oven
because it has to be cooked really
really slow yes i'm gonna dust this in
flour it's amazing how many chefs are
using oxtail on their menus today it's
incredible it's very popular it's very
cheap as well it's amazing how you used
to make it stretch for like five or six
dinners oh don't exactly it's not that
bad now i know why we're all so skinny
growing up
it wasn't that bad i'm joking come on
you know i'm joking but you see
sometimes we went to the beaches and you
had maybe extra two or three i used to
put in a saucepan and you had lovely
stock for soup what was that spicy soup
that really nice
molecules tony and i used to make the
good pot of scotch broth scotch broth i
remember now i'll peel a couple of
cloves of garlic i'll show you a quick
word getting that out get your knife and
just
brush it nice
peel them and i'll crush them in the
garlic crusher okay
all right oxtail in
i'm gonna fry that off we can get that
nice and brown and we've all braised it
in red wine and sort of chicken stock
before but i'm gonna get this done with
a chinese influence the chinese
absolutely love cooking oxtail
you started cooking at home quite early
on right 17 and a half 17 and a half
your mum died quite young very young 26
26 so who taught you how to cook
nobody taught you i think you just learn
as you get older
and you learn by your mistakes i didn't
enjoy it yes
i did enjoy it yeah that was a nice
vegetable the fennel
isn't it that lovely it's beautiful yeah
a lot of people don't use it a lot of
them use it in salads but no one
actually cooks it you just slice that up
them
now these are
nice and brown
and they look lovely put the color on
there
you just slice up the chili okay just
slice it down and keep the seeds in
there because i want some heat as well
star anise that's right yeah i wouldn't
have started putting that in there
one thing you never used to do was work
with many spices there wasn't many
chinese influences i wasn't very
adventurous with spices like me no
i like ginger do you i love ginger
especially fresh yeah coriander seeds a
little handful
10
yeah
some soy sauce
and quite generous in soy sauce about
four or five tablespoons
that helps give it that saltiness and a
nice dark rich color on the vegetables
so as it raises the meat tenderizes
quicker
i would never do anything fennel and
the chilies and
that but it smells lovely does that
smell nice
and then a little bit of
this this is a
a rice wine vinegar where is it yeah
what other tips would you give me in
order to save
money on cooking what got you through
that tough time feeding
all six of us and
holding two jobs when that was in the
oven sea for about an hour and a half
then i would think right i'll make a
roast pudding i put an apple pie and
for the same sort of heat use the other
shelf in the oven so you weren't just
watching the pennies in terms of the
produce you also cut down the gas bill
yeah
wow
super nab
yeah suffer nan yeah some oxtail back on
top of the vegetables gonna top that up
is that beef stock yeah this is uh
a really nice chicken stock why are you
putting chicken stock in it because it's
quite a sort of light fragrant way of
cooking oxtail because oxtail itself is
quite rich yeah chicken socks nice and
light
just cover it with stock lovely colorism
it's a beautiful color
little taste there we go
big deep breath
okay then
well that's lovely i can taste the
fennel in that is that nice that's
lovely
oh jesus
damn water fernand it's morning
take some water now this is not water is
it water come on while mum recovers from
the kick off the chili to go with my
oriental influenced oxtail i'm going to
knock up a quick fresh radish salad
take a bunch of radishes and separate
off the edible leaves
once washed thoroughly place half the
radishes in the bowl with the leaves
chop the remaining radishes in half and
add them too
[Music]
next peel and finally slice a banana
shallot
add them to the radishes and season with
salt and pepper dress with a good
squeeze of fresh lemon juice and a
drizzle of olive oil
then mix
radish salad it's that simple
next up dessert delicious
poached pears i love pizza ready so
we're gonna poach them with a little bit
of chili
chili
never heard of that a little bit of
saffron no
no
no pan on
take off a little slice like that so
they stand up nicely and then peel
okay then and then the chili you hold
that up and just go down yep
through
and open that up okay into the water
seeds in as well
as well
oh
a little bit of chilli
water and sugar what are they holes
saffron is expensive but you only need
the tiniest little bit
a little pinch to make that water go
light and golden star
how comes the chinese you've like sliced
it at the end and it's not put in whole
i want all that flavor coming out of the
chili we're going to make
the most amazing star in east dust sorry
stars dust
should get your star nice in there
seed up and then
in
see all those little seeds
and then
you start grinding
a little teaspoon of ginger give it a
nice mix thank you meg and that's gonna
dust the top of the pears once they're
cooked
right get your pears
drop them in there
[Music]
and that's what we're gonna sprinkle mmm
ginger that's darwinis wow the rice is
that
very good
that's lovely isn't it so once they're
cooked
cool down sprinkle that over the top
right have you guys got homework yes see
you guys come back shortly thank you
turn that down and let them fall
okay bye thank you guys bye
after an eight minute simmer our pears
should be ready now just get your knife
on put the knife through and see how
easy the knife is
so that means they're soft and cooked
now you can leave them in that overnight
two or three days all right and they
just get darker
and more beautiful
the good thing about the cooking liquor
is that you don't throw that away
because you can use that again for
re-poaching
beautiful
i mean they look impressive they smell
delicious don't they
[Music]
look at the colors nice lovely isn't it
those are an amazing one
and just
smells delicious
and then take your little
star and east dust
and just
dust
over look at that nice lovely now for my
favorite part
the oxtail
wow
look at that
that
is beautiful
i'm just melts in your mouth doesn't it
i love the way you see that just
sliding down the bone there's no waste
in that at all no
could you carry that to the table please
then yes
lovely and i will grab that
that is beautiful
[Music]
this is my ultimate thrifty dinner
sumptuous slow cooked chinese braised
oxtail with a light and peppery radish
salad
followed by gorgeous chili poached pears
with star and east dust
jack holly tilly megan
look at this
time to see what you think it's
delicious good nice mom what'd you think
it's lovely isn't it first reminder
day's gone by a lot of people just lift
it up and knit it with a really good
hands no has anyone say room look
delicious stunning pears we have we have
[Music]
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the app store good luck